[Música]
y por ello la me acompaña aquí en el
estudio de france 24 mi compañero luis
méndez para hablar de deportes luís
bienvenido iniciamos con tenis porque el
español rafael nadal ofreció
declaraciones optimistas para sus
fanáticos así valentina porque el nacido
manacor dejó abierta la posibilidad de
participar en la próxima edición del
abierto de wimbledon el tercer grand
slam del año recordemos que durante su
participación en el roland garros torneo
que ganó a principios del presente mes
de junio el balear asomó la posibilidad
de saltarse el torneo e incluso de
retirarse del tenis debido a una lesión
que padece en uno de sus pies hecho que
le ha impedido participar en los torneos
sobre superficie de grama pero tras un
tratamiento aplicado nadal parece haber
recobrado la fuerza y la confianza y
ahora no descarta su presencia en el
gran torneo inglés escuchemos mi
intención es intentar jugar wimbledon
como dije
después de parís si es que había alguna
posibilidad según parece
esta semana que entreno aquí me dice que
puede haber posibilidades con lo cual mi
intención es viajar a londres el lunes
[Música]
y si viajó a londres porque tengo
intención de jugar louis pero esta es
una lección que lleva un buen tiempo
nadal soportando la a qué tratamiento se
sometió el jugador pero hay que hablar
de respecto esta lesión que fue en el
pie izquierdo y días después de ganar el
roland garros se sometió a un
tratamiento de radiofrecuencia pulsada
para tratar los nervios de la zona
afectada que de acuerdo con un
comunicado emitido por la clínica donde
se hizo de hizo dicho tratamiento
generan mucha sensibilidad en ella y lo
que se busca como el mismo es que estén
adormecidos por un periodo de tiempo
ahora porque hay tanta emoción por la
participación de nadal pues porque ha
ganado dos grand slam este año y busca
ganar los dos restantes algo que no ha
logrado otro tenista en más de 40 años
bueno pasamos a hablar ahora de natación
porque en budapest en hungría comenzaron
los campeonatos mundiales de esta
disciplina
recordemos que en esto están todas las
actividades acuáticas por nombrar alguna
en la natación en pileta aguas abiertas
polo acuático entre otras américa latina
estará presente con una nutrida y pasión
y en donde la principal carta estará en
la prueba de aguas abiertas en el reglón
femenino con la brasileña ana marcela
cunha ganadora de la medalla de oro en
los pasados juegos olímpicos de tokio
pero para conocer más sobre cómo podría
estar américa latina en este evento más
temprano conversamos con el entrenador
de natación y embajador de la marca
nadador soy tomás piso no esto fue lo
que nos dijo sobre américa latina yo
pienso que nosotros estaba en una
transición importante como una como un
punto de bifurcación porque como si bien
dices las estrellas de las estrellas de
antaño como meolans y ese tipo de
atletas que tuve la oportunidad de verlo
aquí competir en el panamericano los
juegos panamericanos de santo domingo
yo creo que estamos llegando a un punto
en el que ya por fin nos estamos
empezando a meter más de lleno en la
pelea aunque yo todavía creo que falta
para ponerte de esta manera tal vez unos
diez años para empezar a ver nadadores
con más presencia en semifinales de
campeonatos mundiales y hasta finales
excluyendo lógicamente a brasil no
particularmente en el área masculina
entonces yo pienso que sigue siendo una
muy buena experiencia para los nadadores
latinoamericanos tenemos muchos que ya
se están acercando a los mejores tiempos
particularmente a nivel de semifinales
pero creo que nos falta mucho en unos 10
años digo yo para empezar a ver
nadadores que se filtren con más
frecuencia a esas grandes semifinales y
finales de grandes torneos louis pero en
este evento no va a estar presente la
australiana ariadne team más no estará
presente la actual poseedora del récord
de los 400 metros y gran rival del
estadounidense crítico de deck y sobre
ello también le consultamos a nuestro
invitado si lo vemos desde la
perspectiva de tipos y su entrenador
ya no tiene que demostrar que puede
vencer
al equino porque lo hizo en tokio sin
embargo hubiera sido excelente poder ver
ese enfrentamiento entre las dos mejores
nadadoras de la historia en los 400
metros particularmente porque titus
recientemente rompió el récord del mundo
de tele de kino entonces yo creo que
hubiera sido muy bueno para la natación
mundial
ver esa batalla sin embargo como te digo
y respondo de nuevo o me repito yo creo
que ya tipos no tiene nada que
demostrarle al mundo de que puede vencer
al equipo más allá de digo en eventos de
esta magnitud bueno vamos a cerrar este
espacio con noticias del baloncesto de
la nba valentín ayer cerró la temporada
2021 2022 con el título de la
organización de golden state game venció
en 6 desafío aportó boston celtics un
triunfo que más allá de celebrarse en
san francisco y toda california está
siendo festejado en méxico pues cuantos
canosa anderson nacido en oakland pero
de raíces mexicanas formó parte de la
organización siendo así el primer
representante de ese país en conseguir
un anillo de la nba siendo el quinto
mexicano en jugar en el mejor baloncesto
del mundo transportación llamas eduardo
nájera gustavo ayón y jorge gutiérrez
además es el noveno latinoamericano que
logra el anillo en este baloncesto toca
no en la temporada regular participó de
73 desafíos con un promedio de 4,1
puntos por partido 2,4 rebotes en cada
presentación y 17 asistencias además de
un promedio de 13,6 minutos de juego
después a usted muchas gracias por toda
esta información deportiva de ustedes
por su sintonía vamos a hacer una pausa
y ya volvemos aquí en directo américa
[Música]